hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar examination of microglia at
single-cell resolution in health and
disease I'm Suzy Valdez elaborates and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by advanced cell Diagnostics to
learn more about them visit them at WWDC
d bio comm so let's get started before
we begin I'd like to remind everyone
that this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
send will answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation if you have any trouble
seeing or hearing this presentation
click on the support tab found at the
top-right of the presentation window or
report your problem by clicking on the
ask a question box located on the far
left of your screen this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
at the top right of your presentation
window and follow the process to obtain
those credits I now present to these
speakers dr. Samuel Marsh a post
doctoral fellow in the laboratory of dr.
Beth Stevens at F M Kirby neurobiology
researchers center of Boston Children's
Hospital and dr. Courtney Anderson a
research manager at advanced cell
Diagnostics for a complete biography of
our speakers please visit the biography
tab at the top of your screen our
speakers will now begin their
presentations welcome both of you
Thank You Sussie I'm dr. Samuel Marsh
from the lab of dr. Beth Stevens and
today I'm going to be telling you about
some of our recent published and
unpublished work examining microglia at
the single-cell resolution and how RNA
scope and RNA fish fits into our
workflow and how we use it in our
day-to-day research
so first just to give everyone a quick
background on what microglia are so
microglia are the immune cells of the
brain they are derived from resident
macrophage they are the rest of
macrophages of the brain they are
derived from yolk sac progenitors which
migrate to the developing brain in the
embryo where the blood-brain barrier
then forms around the brain and then
they are sustained through local
proliferation now we've known for years
that there's lots of different types of
microglia and as you can see the picture
on the left here is a diagram from the
original publication describing
microglia back in 1919 and po2 Hart Aiko
who discovered them and named them
showed even then there were lots of
different shapes of microglia that could
be found in the brain what he didn't
know then and what we're still trying to
understand is how those different shapes
correlate to different functions of
microglia and what and how we can begin
to examine those different functions and
we are taking the tact right now of
single-cell genomics to try and answer
what microvias function is in both the
healthy and the diseased brain over the
years a number of different publications
as you can see in the bottom here have
implicated microglia and a number of
different tasks from normal synaptic
wiring to synaptic pruning during
development in the visual system as well
as Alzheimer's disease autism multiple
sclerosis and many other
neurodegenerative diseases and so it's
critical that we start to understand
what's going on with these cells and how
they function in the brain and just to
highlight from my personal research one
of the reasons why I'm especially
interested in microglia is that
microglia are the cell type that is most
heavily implicated in the pathogenesis
of Alzheimer's disease at least as far
as we can tell from genome-wide
Association studies this is a plot of a
number of the different risk genes and
low-side that have been identified both
in genome-wide studies as well as some
rare risk variant studies and the genes
highlighted in blue here are a number of
the genes that are specifically
expressed in microglia or highly
enriched in microglia in
the disease brain and this really shows
that more than half of the risk variants
that we've identified for Alzheimer's
disease are present in microglia and
this really points to them having a much
more causal role in the disease now I
have to admit I took this slide from
Twitter but it I think it illustrates a
point that I want to convey to everyone
in that originally when microglia were
being studied people try to assign them
into the classification system of M 1
and M 2 and these were macrophage
classification systems that were
actually based on in vitro macrophage
work and you were either arresting
macrophage or you were inactivated into
M 1 or you activated into him too and
this obviously as most people can
recognize now was incredibly over
simplistic and in the first place but
then applying this to microglia was
another step farther away from the
actual biology that we were looking at
and so I liked the little poem that they
had at the bottom of this post which was
really we shouldn't focus on trying to
name or classify microglia or any cell
type for that matter into a acronym or a
name or something that makes it easy to
identify them but really we should try
and define them by what they do or we
also think by what specifically by what
genes they express
so our method of choice to try and
understand what microglia are doing in
the brain is using single style
transcript omics so the two papers list
at the top here are the two papers which
pioneered the droplet based microfluidic
approaches which have come to dominate
the field today in terms of single cell
transfer film X and the real advance
that they brought is the high throughput
number of cells that you could do in a
single experiment existing approaches
before this were limited to the number
of cells that you could sort into a
plate and these methods expanded that
into the tens of thousands of cells that
could be examined in the same experiment
the technology that we use here in the
Stevens lab is the technology that's
been commercialized by 10x genomics and
that's what the diagram is here and for
those of you who aren't familiar with
single cell transferred omics in the
first place
the idea of it in general is that we are
in cap with droplets we are
encapsulating a single cell and a single
DNA bar coded bead into that single
droplet that bar coded bead will tag all
of the RNA that it captures in that from
that cell with a specific DNA barcode
then all those cells are pulled together
and by identifying the individual DNA
barcodes we can trace an RNA molecule
back to its cell of origin and thus
understand gene expression at the single
cell level
so this was the approach that we took in
a paper that was published earlier this
year led by Tim Hammond a former postdoc
in the lab and this study was examining
the development of microglia both from
the early embryonic time points into
adulthood as well as aging and what
happens to microglia during the aging
process this is all done in a mouse and
finally we also examined what happened
during a model of white matter injury
and so this is just a schematic of the
protocol that we used in this paper and
the ages of mice that that we profiled
and again for those of you unfamiliar
with single-cell transcriptomics the
typical most common output that you see
are these dimensionality reduction
diagrams using Teasley dimensionality
reduction and what it is is we basically
the analysis reduces the dimensionality
such that we can view this in a 2d space
and each of the different colored areas
on that plot we refer to as clusters and
each cluster is unique based on a
pattern of gene expression of the cells
in that cluster and so what you can see
here is that there we come up with a
number of different clusters of
microglia from all of the different ages
when we pool them all together however
when we break it down and just look at
which cells came from which ages or time
points or the injury what we find is
that the greatest heterogeneity in
microglia actually occurs during these
early developmental time points be 14
point 5 and p5 while once the cells
reach P 30 which is the weaning age of a
mouse and is a bit past the weaning age
of a mouse we now have cells that remain
relatively homogeneous throughout life
except when we get into much older ages
and then we start to see some
age-related shifts we also see
unsurprisingly a very dramatic shift in
the phenotype of microglia when we
perform this white matter injury now
again as I described each of these
clusters is unique based on their
pattern of gene expression and so this
is just a sampling
some of those clusters showing a
particulars highly enriched in that
given cluster and this is one of the
ways in which we can identify and
determine the accuracy of our clustering
is based on identifying transcripts that
are dramatically enriched or unique to a
given cluster
so the next step beyond that is to
examine what a particular cluster might
be doing and what the genes that are
expressed in that cluster can tell us
about what those microglia might be
doing so one cluster of microglia in
particular stood out to him when he was
doing this study and that was a cluster
of microglia that seemingly was only
present at this p5 early postnatal stage
and you can see that on the left this is
a graph showing the proportion of this
cluster at the various ages and you can
see that there's this dramatic increase
at p5 and then these cells are virtually
absent throughout the rest of life and
these cells are characterized by high
expression of a number of markers
including the three that are shown on
the right there s P P 1 GP n B and igf-1
now knowing that these cells exist is
one thing but it didn't tell us anything
about where these cells were in the
brain and that is an important spatial
context which we try and incorporate
into all of our studies because where
the cell is located can tell you a lot
about what is going on and what the set
that cells particular function might be
so the first step in this was to take
one of the cluster specific markers in
this case SP p1 and we used RNA scope to
co-localize that marker with in this
case two markers that were unique to
myeloid cells or microglia and that is f
CR LS and C 1q and so this is a higher
magnification image of a couple
microglia in this field and you can see
the co localization of both of our
microglia markers f CR LS and c1 Q and
in some cases these cells were also
expressing SP p1 though not all of the
cells and that fits with the rest of the
data from p5 now when Tim and his
technician Connor who who really did a
lot of this work and both of them
developed these pipelines for analysis
of this data when they zoomed back a bit
into the more macro view of where these
cells were they started noticing that
these cells appeared almost exclusively
in the developing white matter tracts in
the brain they appeared in the corpus
callosum as well as in the white matter
of the cerebellum and you can see that
here in these images that are slightly
more zoomed out and in fact when they
did a sagittal section of the brain and
then image the entire slide and then
this is an analysis mask of that image
so basically it is using a combination
of Fiji and cellprofiler and some other
programs to basically create masks so we
can identify the cells that are only FCR
or less positive so that's our marker
for all of the microglia in the brain
and then identify the cells that are
double positive for FC RL s and s P p1
and when you look at this whole section
of the brain you can really appreciate
how unique the localization of these
cells
are these cells really are only in those
developing white matter tracks and very
rarely exist outside of that and this is
critical information that we wouldn't
have had if we didn't use RNA scope and
RNA fish to identify where these cells
were because otherwise we you might have
thought that they were spread throughout
the brain but this
honing in on the white matter gives us
even more clues about the potential
function of these cells and a number of
projects in the lab are currently
following up on this population to
better understand the timeline of their
existence and what they might be doing
at this critical point in development
now Tim and Connor also followed this up
in a number of the other populations
that can be seen in these other plots
from the paper and a number of other
cases they didn't see a very specific
localization of any of these cells to a
specific brain region or a specific
white versus gray matter distinction but
even without that distinction this still
is important information because it
tells us that there is a role
potentially for these cells all
throughout the brain and it's again that
spatial context is critically important
when you're starting to consider how the
patterns of gene expression and what
pathways may or may not be activated
with those patterns how those might play
into the function of those cells
so another example where this was
incredibly useful was during aging and
what you can see here and the Tiffany
plots is the shifts in the cell
populations of microglia that occurred
during aging and how with aging we had
cells shifting into these what are
defined as old age to old age three
clusters and there was much more of a
shift towards more a slightly more
inflammatory profile now one of the
markers that defined this cluster these
clusters of cells was the chemo kind
ccl4 now the reason why this proved
especially advantageous to have RNAi
scope is that anybody who has tried to
stain for chemokines or other soluble
molecules in various tissues might know
is that it becomes very hard to localize
what cell might be producing that chemo
kind versus cells that that chemo kind
is reaching out to or just general
extracellular chemo kind that's present
in the tissue
however with RNAi scope because we're
looking at RNA and not the protein we
can define exactly which cells are
producing that RNA and where they're
located and this actually proved
invaluable one to show that this very
small population of cells in the brain
was real and that the increase that we
saw with aging was actually something
that we saw as well and these are just
two images both with the fluorescent as
well as the manual a say showing the CCL
four positive microglia among other just
simply FC RLS positive microglia
now the other thing where this response
becomes important and where the ability
to look at where things are being
produced really comes in in situations
where there is a dramatic increase in
the heterogeneity of the cells and in
this paper what Tim did was to look at a
model of white matter injury which was a
life lesson injection and then examining
the cells 7 days post injection where
there's a significant demyelination
that's then gone on and when he did this
what he found was basically the injured
cells when he looked at a more global
level the injured cells moved into their
own unique cluster which he termed
injury response - but that was a very
global look and so if he just subsetted
injury response - and then re clustered
the data what he found is that that
injury response - actually broke off
into several different clusters each of
them again having some unique markers
but being a much more complex cell state
that was going on with this injury - the
white matter and when Tim went in looked
at the lesion with the simple RNA scope
multiplex a say what again he could find
was he could use RNA scope to identify
ccl4
as well as another chemokines excl 10
and what you can appreciate is that
while there are some cells that are Co
localized in this lesion that have both
CCL 4 and C X DL 10 there are a number
of cells that only have one or the other
or neither of those chemokines being
expressed and that speaks to the fact
that these cell states are much more
complex in this instance and so what
becomes important here is we have two
goals in which we think actually the new
product from ACD the high Plex assay is
going to be really well positioned to
help us in the future and the two goals
which we couldn't accomplish in this in
this current study were one was
localized several very complex cell
states simultaneously in the same tissue
and two to localize
multiple cell states or even just one
cell state relative to many other brain
cell types and how those cells might be
interacting with neurons or astrocytes
or in a case of white matter injury
alleged and recites or legged inter-site
progenitor cells and so one of the ways
in which we begun to address this in the
lab is using the high Plex assay which
you can learn more about in dr. Courtney
Anderson's talk following this as well
as on the AC deep i/o website
but what this allows us to do is look at
a number of different markers in the
same piece of tissue so we can get a
much more high throughput multiplexed
way of looking at things and so this is
an image that comes throughout the
entire layer of a mouse cortex as well
as a little bit of the ventricle and
hippocampus and we first labeled this
with a marker of excitatory neurons and
we chose two markers that we knew had
different layers specific expressions so
using s yt6 and lamp v we could identify
different types of excitatory neurons we
also labeled with inhibitory neuron
marker in this case a broad cell type
classifier of GAD - we also labeled with
the endothelial marker FLT one as well
as a marker of astrocytes
MFG e 8 and the thing that really amazed
us even about this was this was the
first time we've stained four
endothelial cells with FLT one with RNA
scope and even just with the RNA
localization you're actually able to
visualize a number of the different
blood vessel shapes that are present
throughout the cortex and this really
gives us a really dynamic view of how
cell types might be interacting with
blood vessels which is something that
we're really keen on investigating in
the future we also were able to label it
both legged n recites and a legged enter
site precursor cells using sox10 and
pdgfr alpha and then we were able to
localize microglia with FC RLS and the
specific subtype microwave that we're
interested in ccl4 and you can see how
rare these CCL 4 cells are in this slice
there's only a small handful of them
here but the power of this assay is that
we are able to analyze their
localization relative to all of these
other cell types in the same piece of
tissue and so this is now the image of
those that all combined each of those
genes given their own unique color and
what you can see when we zoom in here is
that we actually can look at the
localization of all these markers in
several different areas of this large
cortical slice and get an idea of how
these cells might be interacting and
which cells they're in close proximity
to and I think you can come to
understand how valuable this would be
from the perspective of examining
something like that white matter lesions
or examining tissue from Alzheimer's
disease or another neurological
condition where you have a high
diversity of sub states that are present
or maybe you want to localize how
microglia are interacting with the
neurons in the area this will really
give you a highly dynamic view that you
can visualize all in the same piece of
tissue and so we're really excited about
deploying this in a lot of our future
work with single-cell RNA seek for the
final part of my talk I want to
emphasize one of the important things
that we see about RNA scope and that's
in addition to localizing where
something is spatially or how its
interacting with other cells it can be
just valuable from the perspective of
validating is your RNA seek data true to
the invivo state that's present in the
tissue so this is a little aside from a
this is unpublished data that hopefully
we will have posted soon to bio archive
and this kind of focuses on what we do
when we do single-cell RNA seek we take
this if you imagine that this slide is a
complex piece of tissue that contains
microglia of all different types we then
isolate all of those pieces that piece
of tissue so that we just have the
microglia left and then we feed that
into our droplets base droplet base
microfluidic platform and so once the
cells have gone through the microfluidic
device then we get our result which is
our Disney plot which has all of the
different clusters of cells that we've
identified but the problem comes in in
what if during that process of isolating
these cells you actually introduce
artificial gene expression so in this
case the slot the cells represented in
red our cells in which the gene
expression has changed ex-vivo so these
cells were not represented in that
complex piece of tissue but now
they're present and so when we run them
through our microfluidic device and game
gene expression the outcome that we find
is that now we have this artificial or
this red cluster that you can see here
and this is a cluster of cells which
doesn't exist in the complex tissue now
bring this back to microglia Tim in his
paper where he went through all the
microglia cell states took great care to
develop a protocol that enabled him to
keep the cells very cold throughout the
entire isolation process used mechanical
dissociation instead of enzymatic
dissociation and all this enabled a very
minimal gene expression change when the
cells were isolated at least as far as
their activation profile went however
this is not the case in a number of
different studies that we've looked at
and so one example here is this is a two
figures of a reanalysis from this mouse
brain atlas from stanley nurses lab that
was published last year and what you can
see is in this these clusters of cells
which just represent the myeloid cells
there is a half or nearly half of these
cells have very high expression of this
immediate early gene foss now if we look
at our data set and look if we see fast
expression at any of the particulars
when we find is that there is extremely
sparse expression of Boston general and
it really only pops up in an occasional
animal and to some extent in the aged
condition which may reflect some
activation that's generally happening
with age but the question that we had is
is this a reflection of something that
is different about our protocol or their
protocol for dissociating cells which
was a much more common enzymatic
protocol the protocol that Tim developed
for the isolation of cells basically
only results in the isolation of
microglia or macrophages or monocytes
whereas the neurons the astrocytes the
oligodendrocytes are lost and so to
analyze though
sells more thoroughly you do need to use
more enzymatic dissociation methods but
we wanted to avoid having this potential
artifact here
so in order to look at whether this
signature that was seen in these other
data sets was real we once again went to
RNA scope and in this case we took a
brain that we followed our normal
protocol which was to perfuse the mouse
and very quickly dissect the brain and
snap freeze it for processing for RNA
scope and this represents as close to an
in vivo state as we can replicate in the
post mortem mouse brain and in this case
what you can see in the upper left is
that there are very few if any Foss
positive cells in the brain and there
are there further when we analyzed
whether these Co localized with
microglia it was extremely rare to see
boss and FD RLS double positive cells we
did another experiment where we again
perfuse the mouse dissected the brain
but this time instead of snap freezing
it right away we left the brain in
perfusion buffer at room temperature for
an hour and then snap froze it and
processed it for RNA scope and what you
can now appreciate is the dramatic
increase in the amount of Foss that has
now occurred and so this left us
relatively confident that the fuss that
we were seeing in our data set the very
low level of Foss was fairly accurate
and confirms that we were preventing
active ex vivo activation of the cells
because we don't see fast positive
microglia in large numbers or even at
all in the immediately snap frozen brain
and this meant that the values that we
were seeing in other datasets were
likely the result of ex vivo gene
expression
so how can we test this and can we find
a way to isolate microglia and the other
cells in the brain without inducing
microglia activation so in order to do
this we performed an experiment which is
diagrammed here in which we optimized a
perfusion dissection and dissociation
protocol that involved the use of a
inhibitor cocktail that contained both
multiple transcription and translation
inhibitors throughout the entire process
from profusion through digestion of the
tissue at 37 degrees and in the hopes
that this would prevent the artificial
activation signature that we were seeing
in these other datasets and so on the
bottom here is again the plot of all of
the cells and you can see the variety of
different cell types that were able to
isolate with this protocol and you can
see the microglia highlighted here by
their high expression of TM 1 1 9 and P
2 are y 12
and when we break this down by condition
what you can see is that in the animals
for what they were perfused and digested
with inhibitors there are virtually no
cells in this secondary microglia
cluster this red cluster that we've
turned the microglia activation cluster
and you can see that it's really only
present in the condition where there
were no inhibitors and in fact when we
compare the percentage of cells from
each of the samples in the different
clusters it is only these two microglia
clusters that show a significant
difference between the inhibitor and no
inhibitor condition
look at this another way using a kind of
a gene set scoring approach we can see
based on a gene set that contains
canonical microglia markers you can see
that we can light up the microglia
clusters as being microglia on the left
there and if we use an activation score
which is based on the differentially
expressed genes present in that cluster
analyzed by a pseudo bulk meta cell
analysis we can see that again is only
that microglia cluster that activation
cluster which is lighting up and to
visualize this a little bit more clearly
we can plot those on just an XY axis
here and what you can see in the upper
left is that cells that are both
microglia and activated are present in
that activation cluster and there's
virtually no other cells present in that
in that cluster and this gave us a high
degree of confidence that our protocol
worked though we wanted to follow a
protocol that was more similar to the
protocol that we used in the immunity
paper to validate with a larger number
of microglia that this was indeed the
case and so we did this by after doing
the digestion or mechanical dissociation
with or without inhibitors we fact
sorted the cells to purify microglia
even further and then perform this
analysis so this is an analysis now of
nearly 20,000 cells from 12 mice and
again what you can see is that it's the
condition that received this enzymatic
dissociation Association at 37 degrees
without inhibitors that contains this
artificially activated population of
cells and in fact again when we look at
the same types of analyses that we did
for the data set containing all the
cells again we can see that that
activation is limited to that cluster
and so we can be very confident that
these cells don't exist one that they
don't exist in bebo and to that we now
have a method that will allow us to
examine both all of the other cells in
the CNS along with microglia without
preventing this aberrant activation of
my CLIA that occurs when you do normal
enzymatic dissociation
and again bringing this slide back up
here is that RNAi scope and being able
to do in situ hybridisation was really
key here in giving us the confidence
that this was an ex vivo activation that
we were seeing when we had done a number
of markers both on snap frozen tissue we
hadn't seen anything we were wondering
whether we had trouble with the probes
or whether we had something else going
on but when we continued to see it time
and time again and then we validated it
using this condition where we left the
tissue out for an hour it gave us a lot
of confidence to say that this
activation that is seeing the tissue
doesn't actually exist when we're
looking at things normally
and so with that I'd like to thank
everybody in the Stevens lab my PA dr.
Beth Stevens as well as a big thanks to
Tim Hammond lots of dissing Olson Alec
Walker and Connor dufort for their help
on the microglia dissociation project
which again we will we hope to have
posted on bio archive very shortly
finishing up some experiments for that
as we speak and a big thanks as well to
Tim and Connor who led the analysis for
which I presented a number of things
today that were contained in the
immunity paper which was published in
January of this year and if you're
interested in more of the analyses that
were contained in that paper and how
that both the image analysis and the
single-cell analysis were done please
check out the methods from that paper
special thanks to all of the Institute's
that have funded this work with a
special thanks to the cure Alzheimer's
Fund and the National Institute on Aging
10x genomics and military biotech and
thanks to a CD for asking me to come on
today and highlight some of our work
using their RNAi scope product and with
that I'd like to turn things over to dr.
Courtney Anderson who's going to give
more of a background and information on
RNAi scope and the various assays that
acd offers
great thank you very much dr. Marsh for
that fantastic presentation and thank
you all for joining us today so now I'm
going to go in a little bit more detail
about the RNA scope technology in
general and how you can spatially map
gene expression and genetic variants
with this technology so complex highly
heterogeneous tissue such as the brain
and tumors as well as processes such as
embryonic development are comprised of
multiple cell types and States in really
precise transcriptomic characterization
of these tissues can enable
identification of new cell types
predicted biomarkers new therapeutic
strategies and more
however interrogation of these complex
heterogeneous tissues really requires a
very highly sensitive specific and
multiplex spacial approach with
single-cell resolution and dr. Marsh
already set up this case very nicely for
single-cell transcriptomics I just want
to kind of review more broadly the whole
toolbox that is available for
single-cell transcript omics traditional
transcriptomic analyses have relied on
bulk tissue analyses such as PCR or
northern blot which really provide an
average level of gene expression in a
sample but loses the facial and the
single-cell information this is akin to
the fruit smoothie here seen on the
slide which can be a delicious drink but
you can only guess that what is actually
in the smoothie with the advent of
single-cell transcriptomic analyses such
as single-cell RNA sequencing now we are
able to dissect the molecular
information at the single cell level and
so to come back to the fruit analogy you
now can provide the menu and tell you
what fruit and how much of each fruit is
going into that smoothie
however these techniques still don't
provide you with how those cells are
organized in the tissue context since
obviously tissues are a 3d structure and
so this is where spatial analyses come
into play single cell multiplexing
facial analyses that can detect RNA and
provide transcriptomic information with
that spatial organization while
retaining single cell resolution and so
now instead of that average blended
smoothie with mystery ingredients you
can now see all the fruit and how it is
spatially arranged or to come back to
the tissue how all of those cells are
now spatially arranged
and so a key technology that can help
with this is the RNA scope in situ
hybridization technology it's a specific
and sensitive method to specifically
detect RNA biomarkers and cells and
tissues with morphological context and
the technology has three parts there's a
unique target probe that ACD designs
against your sequence of interest a
signal amplification system that
generates a high signal-to-noise ratio
and lastly visualization of single RNA
molecules as dots the assay allows for
the spatial mapping of almost all RNA
species including messenger RNA long
non-coding rnas splice variants highly
homologous sequences and even point
notations in cells and intact tissues
and all of this can be visualized with
either of fluorescence or chroma genic
labels in addition the assay can be
performed in a wide variety of sample
types including FFPE samples which are
notorious for being very challenging to
do ich in but with the RNA scope assay
it really has been optimized to work in
FFPE tissues as well as fresher fixed
frozen tissues and even cultured cells I
just want to briefly review how the
technology works as I mentioned there
are two key features the probe design
and a signal amplification the probes
are all all of the nucleotide target
probes that are depicted as a z to
emphasize the fact that they have two
regions linked by a spacer the bottom of
the Z will complement and hybridize to
your target of interest while the top of
the Z is the base for the amplification
structure and when two Z's bind in
tandem to the target sequence it creates
a binding site upon which a preamplifier
combined and the tree can be built so to
each preamplifier there will be multiple
amplifiers that bind and then to each
amplifier multiple label probes and
those label probes will have either the
chroma genic enzyme or 4/4 depending on
which assay you're doing and basically
the signal amplification strategy yields
very high sensitivity and allows for
visualization of target RNAs as a single
dot where each dot will represent an
individual RNA molecule now background
your specificity is high high
specificity is high background is low or
eliminated because the signal is really
dependent on the twosies binding next to
each
they're on the target sequence if both
these do not bind next to each other
then the preamplifier cannot form a
stable hybridization and the
amplification tree does not get built so
consequently there's no amplification of
nonspecific hybridization which
generates little to no background signal
now a standard irony scope probe would
consist about 20 of these z pairs that
are pooled together they're designed to
hybridize next to each other along a
target region so you can imagine if you
have 20 of these trees lined up along
your transcript that allows for a
tremendous amount of amplification and
signal potential localized to an
individual RNA molecule however only a
minimum of 3 z pairs is needed to bind
to the target sequence in order to
generate enough signal for molecular
detection so taken together this
combination of probe design and signal
amplification ensures a very high
signal-to-noise ratio
now the arunya scope technology includes
two unique assays to detect RNA at
single molecule sensitivity and with
single-cell resolution RNA scope can
really targets the majority of RNA
species this is a probe that has
approximately twenty double B's as I
just described this really is meant from
messenger RNA and non-coding RNAs that
are greater than 300 nucleotides however
we also have another assay called base
scope this is a more specialized assay
that now allows you to detect RNA
species that typically have not been
able to be interrogated by traditional
ich in the tissue context this now be
cutting down to only one to three double
Z's we can now get down to shorter
sequences so we can target exon
junctions splice variants exon skipping
highly homologous or short sequences and
the range of 50 to 300 nucleotides and
even point mutations so this would again
be four splice variants the CG are three
sequences of t-cell receptors CRISPR
mediated gene editing and so forth
so this slide summarizes the entire RNA
scope and basecoat product portfolio you
can see we offer the assays in a wide
variety of flavors
we have chroma genic single two X
chromosome ik duplex
the multiplex fluorescent line is very
strong we offer it in three different
flavors we have a fluorescence assay
that allows up to three targets in fresh
frozen tissues that's known as our v1 si
we have the v2 si which is now allows
for detection up to four targets and
this one has been perfected to really
work in FFPE tissues which typically
have very high auto fluorescence and can
have potential for more degraded RNA and
then as dr. Marsh is already very nicely
shown our high Plex assay which we
recently launched where now you can
detect up to 12 targets simultaneously
while with fluorescent labeling so now
just to focus a little bit more
specifically on the applications of RNA
scope in particular related to
neuroscience research we've been widely
used for the detection of GPCRs ion
channels molecules where there has been
either no or really not very reliable
antibodies so if you're looking for
specific detection of these molecules in
the tissue context you can turn to the
RNA as an alternative to identify the
cells expressing these targets also
again it's dr. Marshall very nicely
detecting a cellular activity at the
transcript level so identifying markers
such as Cephas or arc when you have to
capture those immediate early genes at
the transcript level for splice variants
the brain has the highest number of
slice variants or genetic variants
compared to any other tissue so we can
now interrogate those place variants at
the cell single-cell level using the
base Co bath day and then again as dr.
Marsh very nicely described how you can
use the assay to validate and spatially
map your single-cell RNA sequencing
signatures and so just to show a few
examples of some images here this is now
showing detection of specific cell types
in the brain so you can use the probes
to detect neurons astrocytes microglia
here really to focus in on the specific
immune cells of using markers that mark
either m1 or m2 microglia
and then also to detect GPCRs this is
now looking at dr d 1 and g RG 2 which
are quite prevalent in the brain and
very important to the text this is
looking at cannabinoid receptors c NR 1
and then here is detecting three
different opioid receptors the mew delta
and Kappa isoforms
and this is in combination now again
looking at that early activity marker
seesaw which can very nicely CO detector
gpcr the cholinergic muscarinic receptor
3 as I mentioned earlier I on channels
are also something that can be
challenging to detect so here was
showing the specific detection of both
potassium and sodium channels as I said
earlier and this is the data that really
supports the fact the brain has the most
alternatively spliced genes really
compared to any other tissue this now
allows for an enormous amount of
diversity in cell types so really from
one DNA sequence you can get numerous
isoforms or protein forms of from that
same gene this can be basically in the
form of splice variants isoforms exon
skipping fork RNAs as a wide range of
slice variants and also abnormal
splicing has been implicated in neuro
degeneration and other neuronal
disorders those is an example here
showing circular RNA detection they are
fairly recently to identify classes
non-coding RNAs where the 5 prime end of
one exon joins up with the 3 prime end
of another exon and they really display
tissue and developmental stage
expression there particularly original
brain but also play a role in cancer and
other diseases but there because of
their recent discovery their role is are
really well defined so we wanted to be
able to interrogate them in the tissue
and find the cells that specifically
expressed these circular rnase so we
took advantage of the bay scope assay to
target specific unique junctions so for
instance in the DL gap one Cirque RNA is
a unique Junction 7/9 that's not present
in the linear form and then vice versa
there's the 910 exon junction which is
not present in the circular form and we
can specifically detect those two forms
of the RNA sequence in the in the tissue
context
so there's this also this very nice
study coming from researchers at the NIH
where they use the base cope assay in
combination with immunohistochemistry to
specifically identify the cells that
were expressing their splice variants of
interest coming from the erbB for gene
now shown here on the left are their
splice variants that they were
interested in JMB and J and a that
either have inclusion of an exon either
16 a or 16 B respectively and they were
interested in examining these
transcripts in the tissue context they
combined base cope with IHC antibody for
GFP which was tagging their specific
cell types either the precursor or
mature and mature oligodendrocytes which
were marked by n G 2 and C n P
respectively or looking at GABAergic
neurons which were marked by GAD and
they summed the JMA isoform
is more predominant in the all of the
gender sites whereas the j mb isoform is
more predominant in the GABAergic
neurons now as i mentioned that the
research of the nih combines base coat
with immune mr. chemistry you can
combine both base coat and RNA scope
with this technique and it's very
popular among neuroscientists research
because it really does allow you to one
detect more targets too you can get your
cell type specificity by using a marker
perhaps four cell marker by IHC or aya
and then look at all the gene expression
happening inside that cell with the RNA
scope assay and also can perform both
chroma gently and with fluorescence so
it's a very powerful tool and I'll show
an example here this is a really nice
image showing the detection of three RNA
scope markers that Mark VV gat and D
gluten Iran and then we combined it with
immunofluorescence for the new and
antibody which you can see here marking
all the neurons okay now really what I
like to focus more on is showing the
application of RNA scope and
incorporating that spatial analysis into
single cell sequencing workflows miss
dr. Marsh has already discussed very
nicely you know you take this bulk
tissue you dissociated into single cells
and you get a wealth of
from these TV plots identifying all
these new cell types and clusters of
cells but you don't still know how
they're spatially organized and it may
also have some bias in these single cell
sequencing analyses so you really have
to do confirmation of those results as
well as getting that spatial mapping and
RNA scope can really provide you with
both of those it's been used by
researchers in over 146 publications to
do this basically a hundred voice expose
users are any scope to validate their
RNA sequencing data and the those papers
have been used to spatially map a cell
Atlas identify new cell type classify
highly heterogeneous cell types even
confirm new therapeutic cell types and
also confirm publicly available datasets
such as the TCGA or tabula myris and
this is coming from the paper that dr.
Marsh had mentioned earlier from
scanline ursins lab where I was a very
nice Atlas that was created of the
entire mouth nervous system both the
central peripheral and enteric nervous
systems and he they basically created a
taxonomy of all these cell types but was
very nicely shown using RNA scope in
particular with this nice spatial
distribution of the astrocytes I'm just
focusing on one aspect of the paper here
where you can see very nicely how the
cells I just like to focus on the image
in the middle here where they use two
genes to really show a distinct border
separating the telencephalon from the
diencephalon
now in addition another tip I'd like to
highlight is using this one for single
nucleus profiling so this is also
another common technique used among
neuroscientists especially when working
with cells that are quite large and hard
to dissociate properly by single-cell
RNA sequencing researchers can turn to
the single nucleus instead and still
capture a pretty good representation of
the cell types in that at the
transcriptomic level in the tissue so
these researchers isolated single nuclei
they perform their sequencing identified
43 neuronal populations of spinal cord
neurons and then they used RNA scope to
confirm those cell populations just
showing here in red and blue our two
examples they also took it a step
further and very nicely looked at the
populations that were active following a
sensory and a motor behavior here I'm
just showing the motor fib sensory
behavior which was basically a formalin
induced pain so they used RNAi scope to
confirm to populations that seem to be
active in response to this pain or a
sensory behavior you can see here very
nicely and then they recreated a map of
the cell populations that are active in
the spinal cord
now again also following up with single
nuclei profile this is another really
nice study that came out of the Broad
Institute at mga MIT where they did
single nuclei profiling of the human
Alzheimer's disease brain they created
essentially a map of the cellular map of
the Alzheimer's disease brain and so
RNAi scope was used to confirm down
regulation of some differentially
expressed genes in particular nt ng one
they found to be down regulated in the
excitatory neurons of the ad
pathological brain and those excitatory
neurons were marked by SLE C 1787
and then this last example here I wanted
to highlight was again another nice
study coming out of the Karolinska where
they created an atlas of the vagal
sensory neuron and you can see here very
very nicely I'm just showing the nodos
neurons they also did this for jugular
neurons but they basically identified
all of these various clusters of cells
and they're all shown here in the kidney
plot and then in the middle here for
every row that's a different gene and
every column is a different cluster that
they identified and so you can just see
the real the breadth of genes that are
expressed in all the different clusters
they then went in and used RNA scope to
confirm these gene signatures in each of
those clusters so again every row is a
different gene and every column is a
different cell type that they identified
and they really got very nice single
cell single molecule confirmation of
their gene expression but I think in
assays that could be particularly
helpful in this case we have so many
genes and so many cell types to analyze
is really the new RNA scope high plex
access assay which we just released this
now allows researchers to detect up to
12 RNA targets in the tissue context and
it has basically what we call three
rounds of four it's an iterative
fluorescent detection assay which I'm
showing here schematically where you
would hybridize all 12 probes you do
signal amplification for all 12 probes
and then you do these iterative
fluorescent detection for the floor for
labeled probes so you do the first four
probes labeled probes you put those on
you would take an image
then cleave off that for four so again
just cleaving the floor Ford not
cleaving the probe or stripping any of
the thing there's nothing that would
harm the RNA to keep the an RNA attack
that keeps the tissue morphology intact
after you do that floor for cleavage you
then come back and label with the next
four four four so four targets five
through eight again you take another
image and then you would repeat that if
you're going up to 12 targets for those
last final four four fours and then with
the high Plex assay we provided image
registration software
so now we'll stitch all three of those
images together by recognizing the
gabbie stained nuclei and now you can
get a really nice true 12x data
visualization at single-cell resolution
the assay is compatible with fresh
frozen and fixed frozen sample types and
I think what's really valuable with this
assay is a couple of things one you can
save precious samples by running more
targets on fewer sections so you don't
have to do as in that previous paper you
wouldn't have to go and do so many
sections you can do all of those
combinations on one or few couple
sections rather than all of those you
also can especially when it comes to
tissues like say brain where you very
quickly change structure as you section
more into the tissue you don't want to
run the risk of being in a different
plane or a different region of the
tissue with the high flex assay you can
now look at more genes and confirm
you're detecting them in the same region
and so this is just a very nice example
here detecting the cortical layers in
the mouse brain and then internally we
worked on a project where we wanted to
confirm the cell types in the mouse
striatum so this is a paper that came
out from Steven quakes lab a few years
ago back in 2016 where they very nicely
created a cellular tax on me of the
mouse striatum using single-cell RNA
sequencing methods they identify very
nice classification of the d1 and d2
neurons that are marked by various gene
combinations but they didn't show any
confirmation of that data or spatial
mapping of the data and so we wanted to
take it a step further and do that using
the high Plex assays
so the d1 and d2 medium spiny neurons
from their paper were each classified by
of eight gene so we could use our high
Plex eight assay to detect these two
populations but if we use the twelve
Plex assay we could then find detect all
of those MSN's all the subtypes in the
same section using the twelve plex kit
and this was actually a work that was
presented earlier this year at an oral
presentation at the ASHG meeting as well
as poster presentations at FFN and the
Cold Spring Harbor single-cell analysis
meeting and here's some of that data
here this is looking at the d1 msn
subtypes all eight markers again very
nicely can see single-cell resolution
and we can toggle on and off some of the
genes in the High Plex registration
software to only hone in on a few key
targets similarly here this is the same
data or similar data but looking at the
d2 MSN neurons and then lastly we can
take all 12 of those probes and capture
very nicely with single molecule single
cell detection all 12 genes that were
identified in the publication to
characterize v d1 and d2 MSN and then
this year is that of just a snapshot or
screenshot basically what the image
registration software looks like it
really allows for very flexible image
registration image image analysis you
can toggle on and off your different
genes of interest so you can only hone
in on a couple of samples because again
as I showed in that previous image
looking at all 12 genes simultaneously
by the human eye can be very challenging
to discern which cells are actually
positive or not so it's taking that same
image now but we turned off ten of the
genes they only kept on d1 d2 very
clearly can see those cells and we even
were able to confirm a result by doing
this
identifying cells that were expressing
both d1 and d2 which was a new finding
that the paper identified so I just like
to end the presentation showing how
re-scope has been well adopted we had
our first paper in 2011 and since then
we've had up to 2600 papers so it's a
well adopted technology recognized by
many arm journals
our top research areas are by far our
cancer in neuroscience but also
infectious diseases and stem cells
and so in summary what we've shown today
is that the RNA scope assay is highly
specific we can use the probe design
strategy to dramatically improve
signal-to-noise ratio from standard or
traditional ish we currently have 22,000
probes in catalogue but any new probes
can be made within two weeks
it's a highly sensitive assay the
technologies is a patented amplification
system is fully optimized assay
conditions with multiplexing and our
newest assay high flex we can now detect
up to 12 targets in the tissue at
single-cell resolution with our assay
base coat we can detect splice variants
and short sequences down to
approximately 50 nucleotides and we can
combine the RNA scope and base go pass
phase with IHC or immunofluorescence to
get simultaneous RNA and protein
detection on the same slide and so with
that I like to thank you very much for
your time today feel free to visit us on
the web or contact us at the email
addresses shown here and on the screen
thank you
and thank you so much dr. Marsh dr.
Anderson for that informative
presentation and we will now start the
live Q&A portion of the webinar if you
have any questions you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on that ask
a question box located on the far left
of your screen and we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for today we
already do have some incoming questions
from our audience members our first
question is for you
dr. Anderson what fluorophores does the
each iplex assay used yeah so the high
Plex assay has four floors that is used
there's fluorescein which is the green
Alexa for 488 side 3 also known as
orange at O 555 5 which be far red h o
647 and then sy 7 which be a
near-infrared alexa fluor 715
this next question is for you dr. Marsh
why is the RNA scope necessary to
validate single-cell RNA sequence and
can you just use amino history chemistry
so yeah thank you for the question I
think the the best answer is that it's
the most applicable because you're
comparing the same thing
so in single-cell RNA sequencing you're
examining RNAs that you've been
converted to cDNA for sequencing and for
RNA scope you're directly examining RNA
there are some cases in which you could
use immunity kamas tree to give the
answer but the issue becomes in
molecules that are trickier to examine
like the case that I described from ccl4
where either the antibodies are tricky
or just soluble molecules in general can
be very tricky to localize to a given
cell type and therefore examining the
RNA directly gives an advantage over
immunities to chemistry thank you for
that and dr. Anderson you mentioned
running is age and I HC together can you
describe that more
yes I had mentioned about being able to
combine the RNA scope issue assay with
IHC or immunofluorescence on the same
section we really recommend that you
would perform the RNA scope ich esse
first and then you follow that by IH C
or I F this is we also recommend also
using a well validated antibody so
basically one that you know that already
works well by IHC or immunofluorescence
and also you really want to focus more
on proteins that are more high
expressing there is a protease step to
the RNA scoped assay in order to be able
to access the RNA so that protease step
could also degrade some endogenous
protein um so you may have some signal
loss particularly if it is a low
expressing protein so again we just
recommend a well validated antibody for
high expressing targets but I would
recommend you contact our support team
on the email address on the screen for
more information thank you
and dr. Marsh we have time for one more
question today
why are micro I'm sorry microglia so
sensitive to ex vivo gene expression
artifacts
yes that's a really good question we
don't have a definitive answer to it but
I think the most likely answer is due to
the biology and function of microglia
microglia are normally in the brain
highly dynamic surveilling cells that
are basically looking for changes that
might indicate an injury or a disease or
something that made they may need to
respond to to restore homeostasis to the
tissue and what happens when you
dissociate the tissue is we believe that
the microglia are simply responding to
that dissociation as they would if the
brain was still intact and that initial
activation wave that we can read out in
RNA sequencing is a basically model for
what they may be doing in tissue in
response to certain types of injury and
so therefore they change very quickly in
terms of their gene expression
signatures and then that is what we end
up reading out
thank you again both of you dr. Anderson
dr. Marrs for your time today and for
your important research I'd also like to
thank lab roots and our sponsor advance
cell Diagnostics for underwriting
today's educational webcast and before I
go I want to thank the audience for
joining us today and for their
interesting questions and remind you
that questions we didn't have time for
today and those submitted during the
on-demand period will be addressed by
our speakers via the contact information
you provided at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand and
lab routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time bye bye